[Music]
[Music]
this is Dave Jewett standing in for
reviewer brett todd kingdom come
deliverance ditches cliches of the
Middle Ages in favor of a brutal
portrayal that wastes no time proving
how difficult life was in the early 15th
century aspects of the game can be a
little too unforgiving due to some
overly exacting mechanics and a host of
oversights that includes a torture a
save system but for its attention to
detail and its adherence to an ambitious
vision Kingdom Come deliverance is
nonetheless a unique and memorable RPG
you play as Henry the naive son of a
blacksmith who has the misfortune of
living in Scarlets Bohemia in 1403 when
the countryside erupted with violence
due to the imprisonment of the rightful
king wenceslas the fourth by his
power-hungry brother Sigismund after a
pastoral medieval day of hitting on the
local barmaid playing pranks and helping
dad finish a sword for the local lord
your village is attacked by an army
without warning all Henry can do is
watch in terror before fleeing for his
life a few steps in front of savage
Marauders all of this adds up to a
terrifying opening that serves as both a
spectacular source of frustration when
you can expect to die many times before
escaping scallops and as a warning that
Kingdom Come deliverance is not a
typical fantasy RPG there's no heroics
swordplay here
no Wizards casting fireballs no clerics
raising the dead no orcs no dragons this
is the story of an actual civil war that
raged across Bohemia and your part in it
is that of a nobody struggling to
survive in a land full of noblemen who
couldn't care less if you live or died
and fellow peasants who would stab you
in the back for a crust of bread such a
cruel atmosphere is actually what makes
Kingdom Come deliverance so enthralling
supported by an incredible attention to
detail built in CryEngine 3 the
presentation brings the era to life from
the filth of muddy village streets to
idyllic Sylvan forests where you can
hunt wild boar or relax while sunbeams
and butterflies sparkle around you voice
acting and scripting is nicely evocative
at the age right down to the constant
religious references that underline the
importance of Christianity God be with
you Kadesh God save can I help you with
anything Jesus Christ be praised the
addition of modern swearing is
anachronistic as is the inclusion of
accents from seemingly every corner
around the globe while there's language
creative
so you can be a little jarring
everything around is so convincing that
you quickly get used to it
game mechanics further prop up the
ambience provided by look sound and
historical detail characters start work
when the Sun rises and head to bed when
it sets you must fit into the schedule
which also involves regular food and
sleep to stay healthy and hearty time
skips are possible although even then
you'll have to wait a minute or two
while the hours slowly tick past on a
clock screen looking after your clothing
and taking semi-regular baths is also
vital show up at Lords manor house in
rags stinging of the stable well good
luck if you have to ask a favor while an
extensive statistic and skill system
provides you with a tremendous number of
ways to customize Henry as he explores
15th century premia he's only as good as
his collective experiences so if you
want to get better at firing a bow you
need to practice the archery range or
head into the forest and shoot wild game
like rabbits
dozens of select small perks attached to
the individual skill categories are also
available allowing you to pick all sorts
of personality traits that govern
everything from how much beer you can
drink to how well you can stare on a
horse there are no shortage of options
when it comes to turning Henry into a
want to be Noble and scholar or a thug a
thief
combat also runs true to the focus on
realism instead of instantly turning
into a warrior when you whip out your
sword for the first time
Henry is a klutz at the start and he
sadly doesn't get all that much better
with experienced ranged battles are
similarly tough due to a lack of any
sort of targeting reticule for your boat
increasing stats and skills allow your
combat abilities to gradually improve
over time but it doesn't seem that you
can get anywhere close to the effortless
abilities typically displayed in RPGs
other actions such as riding a horse and
picking locks can also be overly finicky
yeah as much as such activities can
result in frustration especially in
earlier parts of the game the rigorous
control scheme underlines the central
theme that adventuring is not supposed
to be easy for a village peasant with no
experience of the wider world every
battle in the game is nerve-racking
taking on more than one opponent is
incredibly risky and engaging with three
or more is simply futile the game
features a thorough suite of medieval
armor and clothing options ranging from
padded shirts to full plate butting on a
full plate helmet means that you'll see
the world through a slit battling foes
and armor also presents its own
challenges take on a fully equipped
enemy and you need to either target the
openings of arrows or switch to blunt
weapons better at bashing armoured
extremities despite these complexities
it's disappointing that combat lacks
physicality it's clumsy enough that you
never feel completely in control and
there are odd hesitations in the
animation that sort of remove you from
the immediacy of battles that said
you're generally so grateful just to
survive that you don't care how good the
victory looked even though Kingdom Come
deliverance is built similarly to at the
standard RPG like Skyrim where you
accept quests and follow map icons to
their destinations there are some key
differences the biggest is the way that
adventures are built around the living
world so if you're told to meet a
nobleman adorned you'd better do it or
you may well take off without you this
benefits your immersion but it can make
for a lot of dicey moments Kingdom Come
feels like a balancing act where
everything could spin out of control at
any moment if you miss a scheduled
appointment to start quest or even worse
encounter a bug bugs sometimes prevent
characters from appearing when they
should making you revisit locations to
trigger quests or revisiting old saves
to get things back on track but being
able to save your location anywhere
anytime would have helped a lot with the
above problems
sadly the save system is one of the
worst ever featured in an RPG progress
is saved automatically after you sleep
and a certain moments of play but you
can't just sleep anywhere and saves on
triggered regularly enough during quests
some multi-part quests do not save for
an hour or more forcing you to backtrack
for lengthy periods of time if you get
killed and since you can get killed so
easily here this is a
constant risk you can save manually with
the use of Savior snaps but this
concoction has to be purchased a high
cost which is tough to manage in the
early game or brewed basically the game
needs a patch on a fresh look at some
design elements to let better quality
shine even with its issues in mind
anyone who can appreciate the
down-and-dirty nature of history should
experience Kingdom Come deliverance it's
an impressive and unflinching look at
the medieval era that tells the
compelling story of a real person caught
in the middle of a civil war there are
trade-offs here that make for an
inconsistent experience shoving you away
with quirks bugs and a frustrating save
system although it's still unique and
captivating experience quite unlike most
RPGs and can be easily recommended for
that alone such miserable luck to die by
the sword you helped Forge
[Music]